protests in kazakhstan sparked by anger
over rising fuel prices have intensified
this week the president has ordered
security forces to shoot without warning
he is declaring victory in putting down
demonstrations
with the assistance of russian troops so
far dozens have been killed and hundreds
wounded it's the most serious challenge
to kazakhstan's leadership since
independence in 1991.
joining us now to explain the events and
why they matter is melinda herring
deputy director of the atlantic
council's eurasia center melinda welcome
back to quick take
so it didn't take long for peaceful
protests to metastasize into general
discontent against the government
turning violent in the process explain
how this all unfolded
hi scarlett happy new year yes you got
it exactly right so the proximate cause
is a spike in the price of liquefied
petroleum gas most cars in kazakhstan
run on lpg rather than gasoline but
because there were artificial price caps
and those caps were lifted on january
1st on january 2nd last weekend we saw
protests that began in western
kazakhstan and those protests were real
and legitimate people were protesting
about inequality inflation and a lack of
political freedom and those protests
spread across the country and we see
really chaotic scenes we see buildings
on fire we see airports closed we see
lots and lots of weapons everywhere but
it's important to distinguish between
the legitimate protesters and then
there's a lot of looting and a lot of
that looting is being done in all mati
the biggest city down in in eastern
kazakhstan but this story is not about
the spike in liquefied petroleum gas
it's a lot bigger than that this story
is ultimately about power
so
nazarbayev left power in 2019 and when
he left scarlet he had one condition he
wanted his stolen assets to be protected
but there was a problem the elites
didn't figure out how to divvy up power
which left the new president nazarbayev
hand-picked him his name is takayev it
left him in a really weak position so as
protests spiraled out of control takiev
didn't really have another choice he had
to call in those russian troops because
he did not have the backing of the
security services or the kazakh military
so that's why this is such a big deal
you mentioned that there have been two
leaders and of course there's only been
two leaders since the nation turned
independent how would you compare the
level of corruption cronyism in
kazakhstan versus other countries in the
region
it's high kazakhstan is a is a wealthy
it's it's a very wealthy country because
of its uh because of its natural
resources and corruption is very high
rferl radio for your uh radio for
european liberty has done some excellent
expose into the uh corruption
surrounding nazarbayev and his regime
and people knew about it right so that's
that's part of the the real legitimate
anger that we're seeing but so there was
a legitimate protest movement that got
out of control but i i think it's it's
at this point
a lot is not known because the internet
keeps going in and out and people can't
freely go in and out of the country
right now but if if you have to ask me
to summarize what's happening it looks
like it's a coup
by takaya against nazarbayev it looks
like this is the end of the nazarbayev
era in kazakhstan there are reports that
the nazir by a family has fled
kazakhstan we don't know if those are
true or not but that's definitely
something to watch takayev had to call
in uh he had to call in russia to bring
uh forces in the collective security and
treaty organization they've never
deployed forces before and this is a
complete change in kazakhstan's foreign
policy they had something called a
multi-vector foreign policy they were
always trying to balance interests but
now
they're they're they're they're going to
be very reliant on russia as a result of
this so it's clear why kazakhstan and
why takay have called in russia but what
does russia get out of lending military
support to quash these protests inside
of kazakhstan
it's a great day for moscow honestly
moscow doesn't like instability uh but
they came out on top
as far as it looks now so it what what
it did is it told kazakhstan's security
services to get behind takayev that
takaya passed moscow's backing and it
also allows moscow to prop up a leader
who's domestically unpopular and it's
cheap while reinforcing the point to all
of the neighbors that if they step out
of line uh that they're next
but it says something even i think more
sinister and and creepy it says that
moscow has a weak guy in charge who owes
them i don't think you're gonna call in
the favor right away but he owes them
right it's a check that they can cash
later on
china of course also has their strategic
interest here in kazakhstan because they
share a border and they're important
trading partners because of china's one
belt one road infrastructure initiative
chinese president xi jinping actually
warned it opposes any opposing forces
foreign forces that are plotting color
revolution who do you think xi jinping
is referring to here
so
it's a weird quote right uh yesterday in
one of the major moscow papers the uh
the russians said that they had put
together a color revolution in order to
distract from the major security talks
between russia and the west so moscow is
very good at saying there's a hidden
hand yesterday moscow blamed the state
department for the unrest in kazakhstan
china is basically
saying it's signaling by making this
statement that it's a-okay with what
moscow is doing in kazakhstan moscow
provides the muscle the forces on the
ground and beijing provides the capital
and this is this is a really i think a
scary a formula that could be repeated
elsewhere so this is definitely
something to watch
that is really interesting the way you
frame that russia and how worried should
i be about inflation as a retail
investor
this is trillions etf masterchef where
we end and what's going on there the
unrest there
complicating the upcoming u.s china
excuse me upcoming u.s russia talks
which reportedly won't even touch on the
issue of ukraine because it's too
divisive and too complicated
so analysts are sort of split on this
one some people think that the
kazakhstan uh will not impact the
negotiations next week i for one think
that the russians are uh see the
situation in accu in kazakhstan is very
acute and they need they need to get
stability so their priority right now is
to get stability but i do think the
russians are annoyed that uh this unrest
bubbled up rate as they were trying to
force the west into making great
concessions over ukraine but i think the
talks next week are not just about
ukraine it's much bigger than that putin
has bigger ambitions at this point it
looks like putin probably is has
has come out on top in kazakhstan he's
strengthened his hand and that's part of
his policy but right now he's trying to
use ukraine as a lever to rewrite the
european security architecture and he's
he's pushing and pushing yesterday his
diplomats were saying we want a response
to our demands now so they're unlikely
they're unlikely to to be willing to
engage in in long protracted diplomatic
negotiations it's always the long game
for putin and russia
melinda if you could connect the dots
for us between kazakhstan and some of
the other former russian satellite
states we've talked to you in the past
about other countries like belarusia
which
is also ruled by a authoritarian leader
that still very much relies on russia
when there's a crisis brewing what's the
through line there
the through line is russia
russia has interfered in the in uh in
kazakhstan in ukraine in belarus in
armenia right in the in the past couple
of years russia sees all of these
countries as part of its sphere of
influence
and it is willing to put troops on the
ground it's willing to use information
operations it's willing to use all sorts
of of means uh to to maintain these
countries as part of its orbit it's
saying uh
these countries are ours and uh get lost
west okay so bottom line what does this
mean for the u.s and how much sway
influence washington actually has on any
of the events that are unfolding
so in kazakhstan the u.s is a player
kazakhstan is the unrest in kazakhstan
is important because it brings together
chinese russian american and european
interests so if you look look at the
investment figures in kazakhstan the
number one investor is the netherlands
number two is the united states at 2.24
billion dollars the u.s has a lot uh
private business has a lot of invested
in kazakhstan uh china and russia are
the major part uh trading partners in
kazakhstan so that's why kazakhstan uh
is a really significant country
melinda herring thank you so much for
getting us up to speed on what's going
on in kazakhstan we'll check in with you
when there's more to discuss deputy
director of the atlanta council's
eurasia center appreciate it